So last time we covered a whole bunch of new ideas and that was really quite a
lot of ideas for one class here.
Some of the ideas we covered,
we talked about information says and these were ways to allow us to mortal
imperfect information.
So what's imperfect information?
It's a way of being able to capture both simultaneously and moves and sequential
and sequential moves in the same game so it's not like it's a way that still
allow us to to meld the lessons from before the midterm and after the midterm.
Then we talked about what strategies meant in this context and the basic idea is
strategies,
our instruction,
a strategy for each player.
It gives them an instruction at each of that information sets.
Then we talked about what some games were and leaving aside the technicalities,
sub games are just games within games and finally we introduced the idea of sub
game perfection,
which is our new solution concepts that refines the idea of Nash equilibrium and
what subrogating perfection is going to do is it's going to instruct the players
to play a nash equilibrium and every sub gate.
When I was saying it is a sub game.
Equilibrium is a national equilibrium and the in the whole game,
but in each sum game it induces Nash play as well.
All right.
Now we're going to see today examples.
If we have time,
I'll go through three different examples and I'll tell you at the end of each
example what it is.
I'm hoping to be the takeaway from that example.
All right,
so last time was a lot of formal staff.
Two days can be a lot of examples.
Okay,
that's our agenda.
Here's the game.
Here's our first example and I called this example that I called this game.
Don't screw up for reasons.
We'll see in a minute.
All right,
so this is a game in which player one has to choose between up and down.
If player one chooses up,
then play a two gets to move and chooses between left and right,
and if player to chooses left,
then player one gets to move again and play a one chooses between up or down.
All right?
If we're looking at that game,
so what do we play this game?
Since we haven't played a game for a while.
I'll play a couple of games today.
Um,
so what I'm going to do is let's divide the class into,
so I just draw a line down the middle of the class.
Okay?
Everybody to my left.
Your rights.
Everybody over this side of the class is a player one.
Okay?
You're all player ones.
All right.
And everyone on this side of the class.
Your player to including you guys hiding from the camera.
All right,
your parties.
All right.
Okay,
so this,
it's figuring out what we're going to do.
Not everyone has time to look at the game.
All right?
So play a ones.
You get to move first.
Uh,
those of you who are going to choose down,
raise your hand now.
Raise your hand within,
they're right.
Can You keep it up?
Keep it up to the can see you.
Okay.
And those of you who are going to choose up,
raise your hands.
Okay.
All right,
let's more up those of you who chose up,
why don't you all stand up?
Why should I do?
I don't do one of the exercise here.
So all those,
it shows up.
Stand up.
All right,
so you can see that choosing town ends the game.
So this many people are still playing the game,
right?
It's people to people.
Everyone who's still sitting down,
I want to say we sat down here,
has exited.
All right,
play it too is you get to move now.
so play twos.
Those of you who choose rights,
including the people on this aisle,
there's people who choose rights.
Raise your hand now
one right over there.
Those of you who choose left,
raise your hands.
All right,
why don't you guys all stand up
just to get your weekend Monday morning,
right?
Everyone's,
everyone's sleepy otherwise.
All right,
let's go back to play it twos.
Let's go back to play it too.
All right,
so those of you who are still alive,
so we play a one.
Those of you who are still in the game,
so those of you who shows up at the first time,
they could just up the first time.
How many of you now choose down?
Raise your hand if you choose down and raise your hand if you choose op.
All right.
That's it.
Again,
get a stalling point of this.
It's getting the tools to sit down again so I can speak for people going to need
them to sit down.
All right.
Those of you play a ones who are,
who are still in the game,
who are choosing are.
Raise your hand now.
I think it's everybody.
It's everybody.
It's that.
All right.
It's okay.
You can all sit down.
Okay.
Okay,
so let's just talk about this game for awhile and then we'll analyze it.
Now this is not a difficult game from the point of view of stuff we've done
since the mid term.
It's pretty clear what we should do in this game by backward induction.
So why don't we start that?
Okay,
so by backward induction we find that if player one,
if player one gets to move a second time,
then that choosing between four and three and they're going to choose for all
right and play it to play a two.
If they get to move,
knowing that player one is going to choose up tomorrow,
they're going to be choosing between three if they choose left or two or three
choose right?
So they're going to stay on the game and she's left,
which is what most of you did.
All right,
and finally play a one at the beginning of the game,
knows that player two is going to choose left,
where upon she's going to choose op.
So if she chooses up,
she's going to end up getting four and if she chooses down,
she's going to get to,
so she's going to choose op.
So it's clear what backward induction doesn't this game and that's what most
people did in the game.
Is that right?
However,
not everybody did it.
Some of the player,
once some of the player one is actually right when you raise your hand.
Those are the people who chose,
who chose down,
the ones who chose down.
But more than that,
because in north stand up live,
you didn't stand up just now raise your hand.
People are hiding now.
It's okay.
Those people who chose down,
they may have had a reason for choosing down and their reason for choosing down
might've been that they thought that even though they know they can do backward
induction,
so even though they know that my backward induction up gets them the better
answer,
they might be worried that if they choose up play a two we'll screw up and
choose rights and notice the player to choose his rights than play.
I won and it gets one.
Whereas down yielded to so in some sense down was the quote safe thing to do for
player one given that they weren't,
might be worried that play a two might screw up.
Right.
Does that roughly just not,
if this is the case for those people who chose down,
is that kind of what you were thinking?
Some people are shaking their heads but some people are nodding.
That's a good sign.
All right.
Now why might play a two in facts,
screw up and choose rights because player to might themselves think that player
one might screw up at this stage of clout if by or one with a screw up at the
last stage and choose down.
Then player two by choosing left would only get one.
And for him the safe option,
therefore his rights which yields two.
Alright,
so to get their backward induction answer here,
which most of them we did most of us did to get the backward induction here.
Answer here,
realize plant on player one trusting player two to play backward induction.
And that requires player one to have trust in player too.
Trusting player one not to screw up in the last stage to say it again.
Play a one needs player too,
not to screw up.
And that means player one needs to trust the player.
Two will trust her not to screw up.
All right everyone to do the game.
Okay.
So let's try and analyze this game using what we learned last time and see what
we find.
So the first thing to do is let's,
let's look at strategies in this game.
So player two has just,
Wa has just as two strategies left and rights because I play a two and he has
one information sites and there's just,
this game is actually a game of perfect information games.
Again,
with perfect information there's gonna be very easy play a one has two
information sets,
this information set and that inflammation said at each of them play a one has
two choices.
So she must have four strategies at all.
All right,
so there's this game when we put it in its matrix form is going to be a four by
two game.
Here it is.
And the strategies for playing a one are up,
up,
down,
up and down,
down.
And the strategists for player too are just left and rights.
And now we can put the payoffs in.
So up,
up left gets us for three up,
up right gets us,
uh,
up,
up right,
gets us one,
two,
a up,
down left,
uh,
gets us three one,
up up rights get to us one too.
Again,
we end up exiting the game here.
Down up is easy because it's just exiting the game at the first stage,
so at one of these are going to be just two one.
Okay,
we're happy with that.
All right,
so what I've done is Trump's late to the game into its matrix form.
Let's look for Nash Equilibria in this game.
All right,
just look fanatic,
whatever.
Let me,
let me do it at the board since it's quite easy at this stage,
so look for Nash Equilibrium.
Let's just worry about pure strategy equilibria for now.
All right,
so if player too was choosing left,
then play a one's best response is the ops strategy Hanif player two is choosing
right than play.
A one's best response is either down or up or down,
down.
That's exactly the conversation we just had.
If player too was going to quote screw up and she's right,
then player one wants to get out of the game of medially.
All right?
Conversely,
if player one is choosing up up,
then player two is happy and he's going to choose left.
It's gonna Trust.
It's trusting player one.
If player one was no chews up,
down,
however,
then play a two if that's play a one screwing up at the second stage.
So in that case,
player to wants to get out of the game and shoes,
right?
If playing a one is choosing down up,
then player two is actually,
that doesn't matter that they're indifferent and if player two is choosing down
down,
then once again,
play or two isn't different just so they'll get to move at all.
All right,
so from this we see that there are three Nash Equilibria.
Let me call them one,
two and three.
All right,
so one nash equilibrium is op op left,
another nash equilibrium is down.
Up
Right here.
I have a 30 could I remedy is down,
down right
down,
right.
All right,
so the three pure strategy,
Nash equilibrium in this gate and let's just see what they do.
So the first one up up left is up,
left up.
So that gets us to here.
All right,
so this one is the same equilibrium as corresponds to backward induction.
Is that right?
This one is the backward induction equilibrium.
And the other two are different.
Down,
upright and down.
Down rights both end up down here.
Okay.
Exiting the game.
[inaudible] right.
So both of these other equilibria fell backward.
Induction.
So let's put not conduction with a line through it right there.
They're feeling backward.
Induction.
All right,
so you may ask why are they equilibrate who?
We've seen examples like this before.
For example,
in the entry game we also see examples last time.
So in this,
in this,
in this game,
the reason these are equilibria,
even though they fail backward,
induction is exactly coincide with that conversation we just had about worrying
about the other person's growing up.
All right,
so in particular in particular if plow one thinks that player two is choosing
reits there just to say thanks to player two is going to screw up,
then player one doesn't want to travel up the tree because she knows she'll be
carried down here and instead she just chooses the safe option and gets to,
right.
So from play a woman's point of view,
if player two was going to choose,
writes them,
getting out of getting out of the game,
doing the safe thing is the best response for player one.
And for a player to his point of view,
if play one's exiting the game,
it really doesn't matter what player two says he's going to do,
right,
because she doesn't get to move anyway.
All right,
so that's why these are both equilibria.
Okay?
So what we want to do next,
we wanted to do next,
we've translated this into a tree.
We've written down the strategies.
We want to actually see which of these national equilibria.
Ah subgame perfect.
Which of these national equilibria I subgame perfect.
All right,
let me give us a bit of a roommate because I want to keep this insight.
So let's get rid of those
and raise this one.
All right,
so next question is,
which of these three Nash Equilibria?
Ah,
subgame perfect.
I had to do that.
We need to start identifying the sub games and Paul's having just posted that
bought up that I have to always sit down again.
Okay.
So what are the sub games here?
Well the simplest stub game,
the simplest sub game is this simple sub game at the end
and which player one moves.
All right.
That's a very obvious sub game,
isn't that right?
That's a little game with a game.
It's a rather trivial game cause it's a one player game but it is a game.
So let's examine that one first.
That's the last sub game.
All right,
so the last sub game here is that somewhat trivial sub game.
It looks like this player one is the only mover and they're choosing either up
or down and the payoffs off four,
three and three one.
And frankly we don't really care at this point what player two's payoffs are
cause play a one is the only person who is playing in this time came.
All right.
But nevertheless,
let's put them there.
And if we write this up as a matrix,
here it is as a matrix.
It's player one is the only mover that choosing between up and down.
And the payoffs are four,
three and three one and of course play a two doesn't get to move.
So player to player to a is irrelevant here and clearly,
clearly the only Nash equilibrium in this game with in Nash Equilibrium in this
game is for player one to choose op right by a two.
It doesn't really matter what they choose is,
I think,
I think they can do about it anyway.
But for player,
for player one to choose up is the Nash Equilibrium.
So the Nash equilibrium in this trigger or some game is one just chooses up.
Is that right?
So let's look at the play induced by our three candidates,
Nash Equilibria in this sub game.
All right,
so each of our candidate Nash Equilibria,
here they are this one,
this one and this one in an instruction of how player one should play on this
sub game.
And let me just pause a second.
The reason that these three equilibria have an instruction for how player one
should play in the sub game,
it's because of my definition of a strategy.
Each strategy tells the player how they should move at every information said,
every information ahead of that player.
So even if the strategy is such that that is such that that information set will
be reached,
the strategy is still has to tell you what you would do when you got there.
And now for the first time maps,
we're going to see why that redundancy helps us.
All right,
so let's look at the instructions.
Each of them gives an instruction.
The first one,
the first one tells us to play up in the sub game.
First one says up
the second one,
the second one says op again.
And notice this was redundant,
right?
If once you've chosen down,
you know you're not going to get to make a choice at the third.
The third note,
we all second node,
but nevertheless there's an instruction and it says up,
right?
And the third one,
okay,
the third one says down,
all right,
says down.
So this is the instructions,
all of these three equilibria in this little sub game,
right?
This,
this is the play prescribed by these three equilibria in this sub game.
All right?
Two of them say Aarp and the those ones are going to induce the Nash Equilibrium
in this dog game,
but the third one does not.
The third one says down and that's the loud,
that's not allowed in a sunbeam perfectly equilibrium because in a s I started
getting equilibrium equilibrium.
It has to a prescribed play in every sub game.
That's Nash and here the third equilibrium is telling player one to choose down,
which is not a nash equilibrium.
The Sunday.
All right,
so three.
So what are we doing here?
It just made me make it clear.
We're finding
it's not getting perfect equilibria and what we've done is number three is
okay,
eliminated
because
it induces,
okay,
play in this sub game.
Okay.
That is not nash equilibrium,
not a Nash equilibrium of the sub game.
All right,
we're already putting stuff together.
Now,
this really used to be able to draw this conclusion.
We really used the fact that it's a strategy three contained and redundant
instruction and instruction down at this node that was never reached,
but that helped us get rid of it.
All right,
so that one's gone.
That one's got three is gone.
All right,
let's proceed.
Uh,
I'm going to run out of the board space here.
If people got this one.
Now we've got this down.
All right,
I'll bring it back in a second.
Uh,
almost,
let me give it a second.
Let me give him a second.
All right.
What I want to do now is look at the next sub game.
All right?
Maybe what I can do if I just remove this comment,
like,
and work on the right hand board that that'll aid us to look at it.
So all that comments said was three is eliminated.
And let me work now on the right hand,
half of this boy,
they don't allow it to be out there a bit longer.
Okay?
So let's now look at the next sub game.
And again,
we're going to work from the back.
So the next,
some game,
next time gained back is the sub game that starts from this node.
All right?
That's again,
that starts from that note.
All right?
So let's identify that in a different color.
Uh,
I use blues,
let me use pink.
So now we're going to look at this sub game,
this big pink because I'm game.
All right.
And again,
in this pink sub game,
this game look like it looks like this.
It starts with player to choosing between left and rights and then player one
has to choose up or down.
And the payoffs are one,
two,
four,
three,
one.
All right,
once again,
let's look at the matrix form of this sub game.
And this is a bit less triggered on the last one because now there are really
two players playing.
So here's the matrix that goes along with this
play.
Uh,
uh,
one is choosing between up or down and play.
Two is choosing between left or right.
And this is slightly,
slightly cheating because the facts play one is probably one of course knows
what player two is going to have done by the time she moves.
Nevermind it'll do for now.
All right,
and is it put the payoffs in this upper left is for three and a down left is
three one and uh,
right is one too.
And this must also be one too.
All right,
ever.
What happened with that,
who are just putting,
putting the payoffs in and let's just look again,
just a pure strategy,
Nash Equilibria here.
Okay.
There are actually mixed ones.
Let's just worry about pure ones for now.
All right,
so the pure Nash Equilibria here,
and this is all sub game,
I'll walk when it's to see if two shows left,
then one wants to choose up.
Um,
uh,
if to Jesus,
Jesus left and one it choose up if two shoes is right,
it doesn't really matter what one chooses because she isn't going to get to move
anyway.
All right.
Conversely,
if one chooses up then to wants to choose left,
that's the example of one not scoring up.
So two wants to stay on the game,
but if one was to choose down,
then player two we'd like to get out of the gate.
So if,
if,
if play a two things,
one is going to screw up,
she wants to exit the game.
All right?
Very quickly we can see there are two equilibrate here.
One of them is up left and the other one is down,
right?
All right.
They correspond to and it playing that down this way,
perhaps down right and left playing up this way.
Right?
And once again,
let's look at our three equilibria in the parent game.
Here's our three equilibrate and the parent game
three and let's see what play they induce in this little sub games.
We'll do exactly what we did before.
So one,
two and three.
These are all three equilibria from above and equilibrium.
Number one up,
up left in this game prescribes left.
Is that right?
And equilibrium number two,
down,
up,
right down,
up right here prescribes up rights had equilibrium.
Number three down.
Down right here prescribes
downright.
Okay.
So which of these are scribing Nash Equilibria in the sub game?
Well,
pull laughed as an equilibrium.
It's that one up left as an equal I rent.
So this is okay and down was an equilibrium.
So three is okay in this sub game.
Alright Bob up rights operates is not upright,
is not a magic whatever.
All right,
so in this,
in this some game,
straight up,
Nash equilibrium.
Number two,
the down,
up right equilibrium is prescribing play.
That is not a Nash equilibrium in the sub game,
so it's eliminated.
It can't be a subgame perfect equilibrium,
so here too is
eliminated since it induces deuces.
Norman Nash Equilibrium play
in this sub game.
All right.
I know we're done.
When we,
we know about the whole games,
what we did here,
we started with the whole game.
We found all of that.
We found that the three Nash Equilibria,
we found that only one of them agree with backward induction.
We then looked at the sub games.
We first of all looked at that blue sub game and we found that one of the
equilibria equilibrium number three was eliminated.
The grim number three is not prescribing Nash behavior in this sub games.
Okay.
Right.
Then we looked at the slightly more complicated sub game,
the pink sub game and we found that he couldn't run.
Number two prescribes the paver up,
right,
which is not nash.
And this sub game right at this stage we've eliminated two of the three
equilibria and we're just left with one and the one we're left with the one
we're left with,
the only saw game,
perfect equilibrium there own equilibrium that wasn't eliminated by the fact it
would prescribe bad behavior and sub games.
The only spe is number one which is up,
up and left.
And what do we notice?
We notice that that the equilibrium,
that's the play that backward induction would've selected.
All right,
so notice,
notice this is
the backward induction prediction.
Okay.
All right,
so what are the lessons here?
The lessons here are that on new idea,
idea of subgame.
Perfect equilibrium is pretty easy to go about finding.
You just look at some games and check that the play and each some game it has to
be Nash play.
All right,
I have to be started at the bank.
You construct it by rolling backwards much like we did back in induction,
right?
It started the last sub game and work backwards.
And the second thing is not surprisingly given,
given that remark,
not surprisingly were backward induction applies.
For example,
in this game,
the subgame perfect equilibrium will find the equilibrium that is consistent
with backward induction and remember that's,
that was our aim last week.
We wanted a way of refining Nash equilibrium to throw it away.
Those Nash Equilibria,
that word inconsistent with backward induction,
so Sabine,
perfect equilibrium has done that.
It tells us now if backward induction applies,
the national collaboration focused on are the subgame perfect equilibrium
and indies.
Most people in the class played that he could ever him just now.
All right.
Okay,
so that's really,
well I want
to say about this example but me just make a remark in passing,
I made this market in the middle.
Let me take it again.
When we write down strategies,
those strategies tell us what seem to be redundant moves,
but being forced to write down those redundant moves is useful because it allows
us to model what other people think you would have done at those major nodes.
And sometimes I have to think what you think I would have done at this later
mode nude before I decide not to go down that branch of the tree.
So I'll be able to write down everything in a strategy allows us to have to have
everything in front of us and makes that analysis simple.
And that's exactly what we did here.
All right.
This was a fairly mundane example because in particular we didn't use any kind
of inflammation set.
So next let's look at an example that does use them.
Inflammation,
Sas.
All right,
so new example,
clean this off.
Well,
once again,
I want to play this example.
What I'd really like to do,
got a couple of this game,
the matchmaker game
matchmaker game.
What are they actually like to find out is do we still have all couple?
We tried to send on a date.
I have plus couple.
We tried to send on a date,
uh,
at about week three.
Are you guys still here or there's the guy your,
what's your name again?
David.
And what was the,
uh,
she hiding or is Cesar.
Thank you.
And your name was Nina.
Nina and David.
Good.
Can we get some mixed and Nina and David,
actually,
uh,
let,
let me,
let me do it
and I'll go on talking when I'm doing this,
so that be,
that's okay.
Um,
uh,
where's David?
Thank you.
And uh,
let me grab him.
[inaudible] that'd be great.
Thank you.
All right,
so for weeks we've been trying to get this couple have to go on a date.
It's our,
it's our attempt to get economics majors so it become real people.
It's a hard thing to do.
And they kind of the happiest couple of,
we were supposed to do something to the movies and they're not going to
different movies.
And then we send them off from a romantic,
we came to New England and they end up doing different things.
And one went to the theater and other one apple picking,
I forget which way around it was.
And at this point I figure I'm a pretty bad matchmaker.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to introduce a third player into the game
as the matchmaker.
So first of all,
I'll write down what the game is.
All right.
So the game at this point,
them to look like this,
play a one is the matchmaker.
We can come and play em if you like.
And he has a choice.
He or she has a choice.
Uh,
he,
uh,
she could not send the couple out on the date.
Oh,
she could send the capital out from the date.
Okay.
But being a better matchmaker than me.
If she sends them out on the date,
she's gonna stake some money.
You know,
she'll pay for the date,
she'll pay for the date.
All right.
And in the days,
once again,
they're trying to meet and once again,
unfortunately they haven't figured out where to meet.
All right,
well put the payoffs in in a second or two that the strategies are
all right.
So what,
so what I'm going to assume here is I'm going to let Jake Rta,
br matchmaker.
And the reason I'm choosing Jake is I think he's the nearest thing I can,
I have in mind in this class to being a Jewish mother.
I mean,
he's neither Jewish.
He's,
I think he's not Jewish and it's not my mother,
but
he,
he isn't ca who's responsible for bringing me some drink every day in case I
pass out and the lecture.
So that's,
that's the nearest thing I can think of.
So Jake's going to be a Jewish mother and Jake's going to either send these guys
on a date or not.
And Jake smarter than me at this,
he's actually good at matchmaking.
And what are you going to do is he's going to send them somewhere where they
really,
he knows Yale students better than I do and he's just some really some somewhere
where they're going to meet.
So he's gonna send them to go to the same lecture class next year and then
there'll be sitting in the aisles in this huge lecture class and they're bound
to meet all of you have sat next to other people some point.
So you know that that seems like a good idea.
So the classes he thinks of sending them to,
he says go to a large lecture class.
So they're either going to go to,
uh,
the Gaddis class or which is called Cold War or to the Spence class,
which is called China.
Everyone know what about this passage.
Right,
right.
And these seem like reasonable cost is to go to for it to,
to meet,
to meet your,
you know,
Tommy didn't had,
have a date to meet somebody and when the Cold War and going to fun class,
I mean,
you hope it isn't a prediction of the future relationship,
but you can cold war.
It seems the right and,
uh,
China's by all accounts is a fantastic class.
It involves,
you know,
something involving 20 million people.
Most of them were in the classic [inaudible],
so,
uh,
it's pretty big class,
so let's,
let's do that.
So we'll call this gap.
Unfortunately,
Jake makes the same mistake I do.
He's not going to tell them which classes to go to,
so they have to decide whether to take Gaddis or Spence.
And once again,
they're coordinating,
we'll call them players two and three.
So here they all trying to coordinate and the payoffs are as follows.
So let's put in Jake's payoffs first of all.
So if they manage to coordinate,
well,
first of all,
if Jake doesn't send them,
everybody gets nothing.
All right.
And if Jake does send them and they coordinate,
Jake makes one because he feels really happy about this.
Uh,
after all,
I mean not to be some motivation for people matchmaking.
Uh,
and,
uh,
if a,
they called Nate down here,
Jake gets one as well,
but if they fail to coordinate,
uh,
Jake fields rotten about it,
particularly because,
you know,
he paid for them to go to this class,
whatever the cost of a class at Yale is,
which is probably quite a lot actually.
I don't know.
All right.
So,
okay.
We'll call it [inaudible].
All right.
And otherwise the payoffs are exactly the same as the payoff we used when we
looked at this game earlier on in the course.
So the payoffs are going to be too warm here and zero,
zero if they failed to coordinates and zero zero here if they fail to
coordinate.
And one,
two,
one,
two here.
All right.
So what are the implication of this?
Is that player to who will assume is is David,
is that right?
David?
So David would like to meet Nina,
but uh,
one of the things being equal,
he'd like to meet her at the Cold War and then it would like to meet David.
But all other things being equal,
she would like to meet in China.
I mean,
not literally in China,
but in the classroom.
All right.
So this is our game.
All right?
And we're going to analyze this game of before we analyze it,
let's try and play it.
So,
so,
um,
uh,
what we need to do is,
first of all,
let's not make sure things worked smoothly.
Let's have David write down which class he's going to choose.
And Nina write down which class she's going to choose.
I've lost sight of mean it is.
Somebody needs to point out that actually is right,
right down at Portsmouth.
Choose.
Okay.
Something we'd written down.
And Jake got,
you've got your mic class.
All right.
Jake,
are you gonna are you gonna are you going to send this hapless capital or not?
So,
so I have Dave in my section actually,
and I hear how much he's been talking about Nina.
So I'm going to roll the dice and send them.
All right.
Sound?
Okay,
good,
good.
All right,
so we have them going off to this class.
All right.
And,
uh,
let us see what they wrote down.
So a day,
what did you write down?
I'm going to give it and go to China.
You got to go to China and Nina,
I just ask you to wait until they managed to me too.
There's this successful dates.
Let's give him a round of applause.
All right.
I hear it a great class too.
And in fact,
I don't think it's gonna happen forever cause I think he must be approaching
retirement.
Thompson's a pretty good choice.
So good.
Okay.
That worked very well.
Let's have a look now at this given its allies,
this gay man,
and see what we can do with this game.
All right.
So how are we going to analyze this game?
So no surprise,
we're going to use the idea of a subgame perfect equilibrium.
I'll collect them.
I explains it that way.
All right?
So,
uh,
we're gonna use the idea of a subgame perfect equilibrium.
So how do we,
how do we figure out how to work out when a sunbeam have any good everyone is,
we're going to use the same basic idea that we use it when we,
what we've been using all along and backward induction and they come,
it's the same idea in the game we just looked at just now what we're going to do
is rather than start from the last decision node,
you can't do that anymore and work backwards.
Sort of doing that.
We're going to start from the last sub game and work backwards and then this
example,
it's pretty obvious what the last sub game is,
right?
The last sub game,
the game within the game there isn't it only really won the game within the
game.
Is this object here?
Is that right?
This is the game within the game.
No,
I could at this stage I could just lay out.
I was like,
could write down the whole matrix for the whole game and have uh,
Jake choose the matrix and Dave and Nina shoes,
the row and the column.
But that's going to take,
you know,
it's going to get us a stray.
So it's not that we mean we couldn't do that and it's not worry about that.
It's just let's just start doing things backwards.
So we do things backwards.
We'll start at the last sub game and that last time game is an old friend of
ours.
It looks exactly like this.
This is right then.
All right,
so here's,
it involves players two and three.
All right.
And two is choosing between Gaddis and Spence and three was choosing between
Gadison and Spence and their pay offs where let we leave a space here.
So it was two one one two zero zero zero zero is a,
here are the payoffs of the relevant players in the game.
But while we're here,
when we put in Jake's payoffs as well.
So Jake's payoffs were one here,
one here,
minus one here and minus one.
All right,
so there are any relevant players here play as two and three but I've put player
ones pay in as well because why not?
Why not just keep track of it.
Okay.
And we're happy that that's,
that's exactly describes this little game.
All right.
Now all intents and purposes,
we can forget the first payoff,
but there it is.
All right.
And this is a game we've seen many times so far.
It's the battle of the sexes or the battle of Dave and Nina.
And,
uh,
in this game we already know what the equilibrium Ra.
So,
uh,
the,
equilibrium here,
I mean it's underlying,
uh,
best responses.
Uh,
so if,
uh,
if Nina is choosing Gaddis,
then Dave chooses gas.
If neither is choosing Spence than Dave would like to choose Spence.
And,
uh,
conversely,
all right,
so I just underlined the best responses for the players who are actually
involved in the game.
I haven't bothered underlining and thing for Jay because he isn't a player in
this game.
That makes sense.
All right,
so the pure Nash equilibrium in this game,
a pure Nash equilibrium in this game are essentially Gaddis Gaddis or Spence.
Spence.
Alright.
I have a pretty easy,
all right.
And from Jake's point of view,
each of these pure strategy,
Nash Equilibria yield a pay off of here for him.
Of what,
how,
what does he get if they,
if they go to Gaddis Gaddis he's happy that they magically gets one and if they
choose Spence Spence,
he's happy that they met and he gets one.
Jake doesn't really matter.
[inaudible] himself doesn't really mind whether Dave and Nina,
uh,
learn about China or learn about the Cold War.
He just wants them to meet.
All right,
so both of these,
uh,
yield one for Jake,
both yields he valued it was cool value of one for plan one for player one.
Who's Jake?
All right.
So from Jake's point of view,
from Jake's point of view,
going back a stage and we're going to do now,
it doesn't mean it just made it with backward induction.
We're going to roll the game back.
So we started by analyzing this sub game and then we're going to roll back a
stage just as we did with backward induction.
So when we rolled back,
Jake,
he's moving here.
If Jake chooses not to send them not to send them,
then we get zero,
zero,
zero.
But the key part of this is the first year that's Jake's payoff.
And if Jake's sends them,
if Jake sends them,
they weren't Jake gets is the value
to Jake.
Oh well okay.
I'll put it Jake,
but play player while,
okay.
Value for Jake.
All of the Nash Equilibria in this subject.
Okay.
Right.
Well the big thing to write but that's what,
that's what Jake gets on the others do to that.
Let's get that as well.
And in this case,
in this case,
rather than waiting that long piece,
this is just equal to one that right.
All right.
So if Jake sends them,
he knows that they're going to play a nash equilibrium in this some game or he
believes they're going to play a nash equilibrium in this sub game and either of
those two national whatever on the sum game.
I think I got second either of the two Nash Equilibrium,
the sum game yield a pay off to Jake of one.
All right,
so actually uh,
the,
the one of them is one,
one of them.
You'll pay payoffs of one,
one,
two and the other yields payoffs of one to one.
But since Jake is the only mover here,
lets us focus on Jake.
All right,
so from Jake's point of view,
he's really choosing between zero and one.
So he's going to choose sent.
All right,
so the national search,
so the subgame perfect equilibrium,
the subgame perfect,
whatever.
I'm therefore they're actually two of them here.
One is
Cindy Spence,
Spanish.
That's what actually happened.
But there's another one which is
send Gaddis Gaddis.
Right?
That would also have been a pure strategy.
Uh,
it's like getting perfect.
He could ever write.
In either case,
what we did is a rock,
just to remind ourselves,
we first of all sold the equal rim down the sum game,
the equilibrium in this blue sub game.
We figured out how much that equilibrium was worth for everybody,
but in particular for Jake,
but in for everybody.
And then we rolled that payoff back and looked at Jake's choice,
right?
In this particular case,
that gave us to whenever send Spence Spence and send Gaddis Gaddis.
However,
some of you must be suspecting at this point that there's actually another
subgame perfect equilibrium here,
right?
How do we know that?
What does the thing about this game,
I mean we've been trying to send this couple on a date or all semester.
They haven't gone on a date or some acetone embarrassing now,
but they haven't gone a day all semester.
So there must be some possibility that they would fail to coordinate and it'd be
a pretty weird notion of equilibrium that concluded that they always managed to
coordinate and hence Jake always wants to send them.
Is that right?
So let's also look at the other equilibrate here.
Now the reason there's another equilibrium in this sub game.
Yeah.
The reason,
the reason is that another equilibrium equilibrium in the whole game,
there isn't,
there's another sub game.
Have any on in the hallway,
you mean is that there's another nash equilibrium in the sub game.
What's the other Nash Equilibrium in the sub game?
They could mix,
right?
They could mix.
Right,
right.
It turns out that in the sub game,
in the sub game,
here it is.
There's also a third mixed equilibrium.
Okay.
That is a mixed,
Nah,
she could I rent
all right.
And we can,
we know how to work that out.
We could,
we could write down a p in a queue and we can look at those indifference
conditions and solve it out.
But this is a sub game.
This is a game.
This,
this top game corresponds to a game we've seen many times in his past so far.
And I think we probably remember what that equilibrium is that right?
I do anyway.
So if it's,
if you remember it as well,
I write down and we'll see if you'd all look alarmed.
So I claim the equilibrium at the other equilibrium has Dave playing with
problems.
He two thirds,
one third and has Nina playing with property one third,
two thirds.
Alright,
so this is another equilibrium in the sub game.
People remember that this was an equilibrium.
A battle of the sexes.
Yeah.
People nodding at me.
Okay.
So,
so it isn't until an intuitive we,
we can,
we all know how we'd work it out.
We can go back and put it on the p in the queue,
but it isn't quite an intuitive.
It has a day of going more often to the lecture course.
He would prefer all of the things being cool and it has me,
they're going more often to the lecture course that she would refer.
All the things be equal and they do just such a way as to make each of them in
difference.
All right.
Now this some game induces a different value for Jake,
right?
It's,
I suppose Jake thinks I trust Dave and Nina to play a nash equilibrium in there.
Some game,
but I don't know which one it is and I think maybe they're going to play this
one.
All right.
So suppose it,
suppose Jake thinks that this is the equilibrium that Dave and neither going to
going to play.
So now should Jake send them or not?
Well let's work it out.
Let's work it out.
So now,
now if he sends them,
yeah,
if Jake since Dave and Nina and weren't honestly if plow one sentence players
two and three.
Okay.
Alright then
with what prevalency will they meet?
Okay.
In what problems do you,
will they meet?
Well this is just a little math exercise that's kind of look at the game again.
So Dave is playing two thirds.
One third is that right?
And Nina is playing
two thirds.
One third.
All right.
It's not right.
So the probability of that meeting is probably of this box.
They could meet it Gaddis plus the property of this box.
They can meet at Spence.
Is that right?
So the problem is that this box is one third times two thirds.
So this box has problems.
The two ninths and the problem with this box is two third times one third.
So this problems he had,
this box has probably two ninth so the problems that their meeting is two nine
two plus two ninths that makes four nights,
right,
Evan.
Okay with that.
Alright.
So
if Jake sends Dave and Nina and they play this mix strategy agreed equal over
him and then they meet with probable c two ninths plus two nights,
two nights at gas to ninth expense for a total of four nights.
Right.
Which means they fail to meet.
Yeah.
And hence fail to meet
with probability.
One of my meeting with 44 nine what must be the property that they are fading to
me is five.
Nine thank you.
So they failed who it was probably five nights.
Alright,
so Jake's expected payoff if he sends them.
The value for Jake of this equilibrium is worse.
So the value,
the value to Jake of this nash equilibrium if he sends them is four ninths times
one plus five ninth times minus one for a total of minus ninth
and we're okay with that.
Alright,
so if Jake sends them,
they fail to meet five months at the time and he gets minus one each of those
times basic seed in meeting for ninth of the time,
he gets plus one each of those times.
So his expected payoff is expected value from sending Dave and Nina on the date
is minus and ninth.
All right.
So from Jake's point of view,
what this game looks like,
if he thinks this is the,
if he thinks that this is the nash equilibrium being played,
if he doesn't send you get zero.
And if you does,
he get to the value of this nash equilibrium,
which in this case is minus one ninth so he's not going to send.
All right.
And the SBA here is
not sand
mix mix.
All right.
Where this where this is the Vegas.
Alright,
so there's a 30 equilibrium here in which our match me,
Kat says this hapless couple is just to hapless.
They're going to play the mixed strategy equilibrium,
in which case it isn't worth my while sending them on my date.
You guys were lucky because Jake shows the other week whenever it was,
I figured you're playing the old agreement.
You could have him,
which it turned out that you were all right,
so in this game there were three subgame perfect equilibria,
one for each of the magic,
whatever in the sub game was.
It turned out there was one in which Jake sent them and they coordinated on the
pure strategy equilibrium in the game.
S s there was one in which Jake sent them and they coordinated on the pure
strategy needs to be clear from the sub game GG on this one in which Jake didn't
send them,
but have you in fact send them?
They would have both mixed and hence for a lot of the time,
fail to coordinate.
All right,
watch the big lesson here I,
the big lesson of the first game we saw this morning was that subgame perfect
equilibrium implies backward induction,
right?
The big lesson of this game,
other than the fact that we're getting close to they're getting Dave and mean it
on that date.
The big lesson of this game is to show that the find subgame perfect equilibria.
All you have to do is keep your head and sold out the Nash Equilibria in each of
the sub games.
Roll the payoffs back up and then look for behavior up the tree.
All right.
Once again,
you look for the national equilibrate and each of these sub games roll the pay
off backup and then see how behavior is to what the optional moves are higher up
the tree.
All right,
so we have time to do one more example.
Alright.
And the third example I want to do is more of an application.
All right?
So,
so far we've seen fairly simple examples.
Now I want to do an application
and the application I want to do is kind of a classic business school case if
you like,
or mini case,
uh,
involving strategic investment.
Um,
the game is this,
all of the setting is this,
there were phones,
we'll call them a and B,
and these two firms initially before we start considering the fork,
before you start initially,
uh,
considering what we're actually going to talk about initially,
they are playing corn.
Oh,
competition.
So two firms
and that playing corno competition.
How are we going to mention that they're producing fertilizer,
right?
Imagine that that producing is that,
why is that?
All right?
And let's be specific here.
Let's assume that the prices in this market are given by the following demand
curve.
Two minus one,
third times Qa plus QB.
Alright,
so this is the demand curve that they face.
All right?
And we'll assume that costs marginal costs C is equal to a dollar a ton.
All right,
so this is,
this is the,
this is the price in dollars per Tom Price.
Baton in dollars and the costs are a dollar per ton,
right?
I'm in a minute.
What we're gonna do is we're going to consider a change in this game,
but before we do that,
let's just remind ourselves what the corner equilibrium of this game would look
like.
All right,
let's do a bit of a review.
It's a while since we've seen Cornell.
It was,
that's remind ourselves,
so I claim,
I claim that the quantity,
the core,
no quantity chosen,
Q star has the formula a minus c over three beam.
Is that right?
If you go back in your notes,
you'll find it.
So we,
we,
and I'm not going to resolve it here.
We've done it many times.
So a minus C minus three B.
Trust me is what came out of our calculation before the midterm.
And what I want to do is I just want to make sure we can translate that into
numbers here.
It's all very well having a letters.
But let's translate into numbers.
So in particular this a,
this a is this to that,
right?
This si is this one and this be is this third,
is that right?
So let's just put that down.
So what this is in this case,
this is two minus one over three times a third,
right?
Two minus 100 times three minutes.
The third.
So this says that the quantity is what this is.
This is,
this is million tons.
So the quantity here,
the corner quantity is a million tons each,
right?
So one each.
So each and this equilibrium it,
each of these two firms is producing a million tons of fertilizer.
All right,
and what else do we know?
We know therefore what prices must be and it to do that before we even get
started.
So prices must be two minus a third times the quantity.
That's the first phone producers plus the quantity that the second from
producers.
So that's two minus two thirds.
So that should be four thirds.
If I got that right,
or one and a third.
So prices here are $1 and 33 cents per time,
alright?
And finally,
profits.
So profit for each from here and this equilibrium before we even start the game.
The more interesting part of the game,
profit is what?
So they're going to get $1 and one third for every time they produce.
It's going to cost them $1 to produce each time.
And they're producing 1 million of these things.
All right?
So their profits are
to be a dollar sign here as well.
Their profits are,
or one third.
If there's a millions and producing one third that there's that there's,
or that their profits are one third of $1 million.
All right?
So this is their prepared profit,
right?
In each period they're doing this,
each year they're doing this and this is that profits in each period.
I,
this is the simple model we've done many times before.
This is core know,
and now we're going to make it more interesting.
Well,
everything.
If the Algebra here,
it was a bit quick,
don't worry about it,
check it at home.
It's very,
it's just basic,
basic Algebra.
All right.
So now suppose that you are the manager of from a
classic understated classic business school case.
I'm looking at my business school students in there.
In the balcony,
right?
You're the manager of May and you have to choose whether to uh,
accepts a,
an offer to rent a new machine.
I went to this new machine has two features,
okay?
Right?
The first,
well,
three features.
The first feature is it only works Faye to this machine is being offered to you.
It wouldn't fit in to from bees technology.
So this is only being offered for a,
the second feature of this machine is it costs point $7 million in rental.
So each year you rent this machine,
you'd have to pay point $7 million,
all right?
But that's not so bad news.
The good news is it will lower
costs to 50 cents a ton.
Okay?
All right,
so plot classic business school situation.
You're the manager of,
you're involved in competition with another firm B,
and suddenly an opportunity comes along to rent some new technology.
It's going to cost you 0.7 a year to rent this machine.
But it will lower your costs by 50 cents a ton.
All right?
This is a classic thing that you might be asked in your interview for Morgan
Stanley next week.
How many of you were interviewing with investment banks?
There's no one's going to admit it in a couple of years when you're in bed,
when you're interviewing with them,
with these guys.
All right,
so what's the obvious question?
The obvious question is,
should you go ahead and rent this new technology or not?
Should you rent this
or not
to rent or not as a rent
to rent an alternate?
Less dramatic than it.
It's a coolant question to the English class,
but important nevertheless.
All right,
is board is stuck.
Unfortunately,
I don't have to rate that a bit more.
There we go.
All right?
So what I want to do
is I want to analyze this three times,
and each time I analyze it,
I want us to see what I'm doing,
what mistakes I'm making.
Because I want you guys,
when you interview with Morgan Stanley about this kind of thing to impress them
so that they tell us we will come to Yale and preferably give lots of money to
Gail.
All right?
So we're gonna look at this way three different times.
And the first thing we're going to do,
the first one we're gonna look at this is look at it as if we were accountants.
We're going to look at the accountants answer to this question.
And some of you may decide you don't want to integrate with Morgan Stanley or
Mckinsey.
You might want to interview her for some,
uh,
some accounting firm when you leave Yale,
God forbid,
but you might.
All right,
so let's have a look at how the accountants would answer this question.
All right?
So I think the accountants would do this.
They would say,
but before we do this,
that's of a poll.
How many people think you should rent?
You've got to time to think about it now.
So how many people think you should rent the new machine?
Okay.
I don't even think you should not run the new machine.
Yeah.
Oh No,
I'm not gonna lie to extensions.
Yeah,
let's try it again.
All right.
Without no extensions,
right?
You've got to defend it.
You come out of Spain and the interview.
All right,
so you're on the spot.
You're in the board room.
All right.
How many think you should rent the new machine?
Okay,
raise your hands.
Waved them in the air.
How many things are not rent the new machine?
All right,
so we're split kind of in the middle.
I'm looking at my MBA students,
see which they voted?
Which you guys both rent,
rent,
or not vote rent.
Okay.
NBA think rents will see if that's right.
All right,
so it's move forward.
so accounting accountants aren't set,
so I think what the counter is going to say is this.
They're going to say Purdue right now,
you're producing a million tons a year.
All right.
The new machine saves you a yes,
but that's said to put per annum.
Let's try,
let's try and be fancy here and million tons per annum.
The new machine saves you 50 cents.
Hi Tom.
So if you rent this new machine,
you're producing a million tons a year,
it's going to save you 50 cents a ton,
so it's going to save you
1 million a year in variable costs.
Okay.
Right,
and those people do in one 15 or one 50 no one.
I mean,
my variable cost is the cost.
You're going to save it in actual production of your fertilizer.
So it saves you half a million a year.
Right?
Unfortunately,
it costs you
cost of machine,
which is a fixed cost.
There's a fixed cost of
point 7 million a year.
I 0.7 is bigger than 0.5 so you should not rent.
Okay.
All right,
so 0.5 is less than 0.7 so don't rent the machine.
All right.
How many of you said no,
this is kind of,
that was that,
that's kind of the back of the envelope calculation you were doing,
is that right?
I'm just going to back of an envelope calculation that accountants do.
So what's going on here?
And I,
business school student up in the balcony says you should rent.
He took accounting.
I know he did that cause you have to accounting at business school.
So what's wrong did,
did,
did he fail accounting or if this answer wrong,
the answers wrong.
All right?
There's two things you need to know about accountants.
One is that they're usually boring and the other is that they're often wrong,
right there more often boring than wrong,
but that they're almost always boring,
but all right,
so this is this.
The answer is kind of boring,
right?
And it happens also to be wrong.
Why is it wrong?
It's wrong because we made an assumption here.
That's not a good assumption.
We made the assumption that you're going to go on producing
the same amount per year or after you've invested in the new machine that lowers
marginal costs as you are producing beforehand.
All right?
All right.
We made the assumption that it would lower your,
we know it lowers your cost and we assumed implicitly you'd go on producing a
million tons a year,
but that's not rights.
So let's try and have a more sophisticated answer.
And if you want to be more sophisticated and less boring than accounts saying
what class would you want to take?
An economics?
Probably.
Right?
All right,
so let's look at an economic saucer.
It took an economics one 15 I'm sorry,
how many of you have taken economics?
15 how many you didn't want to at one 15 at the moment?
Quite a few.
Okay,
so let's have a look at an economic salsa.
Let's see why that previous answer was wrong.
So here is Qa and here is
cost of a dollar.
You're new.
Costs will be 50 cents.
All right,
I'm putting prices and costs on this access.
Alright?
And here is your residual demand curve.
This is the demand curve you face after the other guy has finished producing.
So this is your residual demand curve.
It's the demand curve on that part of the market you're supplying.
Well,
not being supplied by the other side of the market and to figure out your
optimal quantity on your residual demand curve,
what you should do it like you're,
you're a monopolist on this residual demand curve.
So you should set what?
Yes.
And again,
Chad.
Yeah,
if the answer isn't backward induction,
it's probably marginal revenue equals marginal costs,
right?
So let's try the hat.
So,
uh,
here's the marginal revenue curve,
right?
Roughly speaking,
it should be twice as steep.
This is residual marginal revenue.
All right?
And here's what you used to produce,
right?
So we know what this is.
This was a million tons when this was marginal revenue hitting marginal costs.
Now your costs have gone down.
So gnosis that your quantity,
your new quantity has gone up,
your new contract has gone up because you've slid down the marginal revenue
curve as the marginal cost curve dropped that clear to everybody.
All right,
so this is the kind of picture that you probably saw a lot of in one 15.
Is that right?
Or in one 50 for that matter?
Is that correct?
So notice in this picture we can actually see the accountants aren't,
are the boring old.
Say the boring answer is this rectangle,
right?
This rectangle,
this is the accounting answer.
This rectangle is 0.5 times one.
So it comes out as a half.
And there's that to think that we're the accountants answer.
And what did they miss?
What are they?
Accountants mess.
Yeah,
they missed the triangle,
right?
They missed the triangle.
They missed this triangle.
So I,
I told you they were boring.
They're a little bit square,
so they tend to miss triangles.
All right?
So here's the triangle that they missed.
Did we miss this triangle?
Okay.
All right.
And how big is this triangle?
What we could do it at home.
It's half base times height.
All right?
So we could figure this out.
We know the slope of this line.
We know the slope of this line is a third.
We or the slope of this line is two thirds.
We know that the height of this triangle is a half.
Uh,
we know,
uh,
we,
we could figure out what the width is as well.
Therefore we can do half base times height.
Turns out that this has area.
Okay.
Uh,
I did this at home,
so let me just write it down.
Uh,
it has area three-sixteenths.
Alright,
so again,
everyone,
everyone could figure out the area of a triangle at home.
Is that right?
You all know that from your probably in junior high school geometry.
So as soon as I did it correctly at home,
this is three 16 which is approximately 0.19 right?
It's,
we missed this 0.19.
You missed this 0.19.
All right,
so how are we doing now?
So we know from the accounting arm,
sir,
we had a hall in savings.
We know from the economics aren't sir,
that we should add another 0.19 to this.
That's the triangle for a total of 8.69
yeah.
But unfortunately this is still less than 0.7,
which is the cost of the machine,
the prime cost of the machine.
So it looks like we should still not rent.
So even after taking economics one 15 which is a good thing to do and is much
less boring than accounting,
and we'll get you the accounting officer or anywhere.
If you do things carefully,
we still end up concluding you shouldn't rent.
But all guy from the business school said you should wrench,
right?
So did he feel economics is what I was accounting or is this answer wrong?
There's also still wrong.
This owns just still wrong.
Oh,
okay.
All right,
here we go.
We've got board is broken.
All right,
this answer's still wrong.
Didn't really want to delete that.
That's a shame.
Well done now.
All right,
you've all gotten his number somewhere.
I have that in my notes.
There's almost,
this is still wrong.
We need to get the writer on the side.
All right?
So what we need is a third down side,
which is the game theory.
I'm sir,
which is also known as the right answer.
All
right,
what are we missing?
What's wrong with the economics?
Answer somebody.
What's wrong?
Everyone knew was wrong.
Why is it wrong?
It looked pretty good.
What's wrong with it?
And says it's bounced down here,
but something in the front row will help me.
Why is this,
what did I do wrong from the also changes it's quantity.
We assumed in the accounting onset,
we assumed that from a captain's quantity fix that we kept up on to fix and that
was wrong.
But in addition from B is going to change it's quantity,
isn't it from B is going to change it's quantity.
Let's have it.
Let's remind ourselves why we're still playing corner competition.
Here's our corn.
Oh,
diagram with Qa and QB.
So prior to making this investment,
the model is symmetric.
Here it is,
and this is the old best response of a,
and this is the best response of I'm be
all right.
And what we've learned,
what we learned just now in the economic song,
sir,
is what we learned that from a,
as its costs go down,
it will produce more for each possible content that from a beat,
you produced it.
So regardless of what generated this residual demand curve,
as the costs go down for,
for me,
it increases it's quantity.
All right?
So we'll know that.
We know that.
So what's that telling us?
It's telling us that the new best response of Fermi is shifted
to the rice.
This is the new best response from a,
it shifts to the right now,
but it's just more for any given quantity that from be producers.
Alright,
so Qa has gone up.
That was our economics onsite.
All
right?
But that leads from B to do what?
To produce last.
That leads to be producing less.
And it was just,
we slid down from bes best response line from the old equilibrium to the new
equilibrium and at the new equilibrium from bees production has gone down.
By the way.
What kind of game?
What kind of game is it?
Where as from a increases its strategy from be decreases it strategy and
response.
Strategic substitutes.
Right?
So because this is a game of strategic Starbucks,
it's use strategic substitutes.
Okay,
good interview word,
right.
Good word,
dimension.
An interview.
Because this is a game of strategic substitutes.
We know that from B reduces its quantity as from B,
it reduces its quantity.
Is that good for a or bad for a,
it's good for right,
right.
This is good for a,
this is good.
Full from,
hey,
it's softened its competition.
I it softens competition.
Right,
and as a consequence it leads to the increase in profit.
Again,
we could,
we don't have time today,
but we could do is we could go back and we could recalculate the new core.
No equilibrium.
Right?
We could calculate this.
We could,
there's a homework exercise.
Try it.
How your lights,
the new
Nash Equilibrium and notice this is a nash equilibrium in a sub game.
All right.
Why is this a sub game?
Because from a made its decision whether to buy this new machine or not and then
they played corner.
Those are the core.
No game.
The game up here.
What is this?
This is the sub game.
All right.
This is the diagram of the sub game.
If you're like right,
what is the best response?
The best response isn't the side gate.
So what [inaudible] tells us to do here is first of all,
we'll count the new equilibrium in the sub game workout.
How much that new Collibra is worth for from a,
and then roll it back to the investment decision.
Right?
It turns out it turns out when we do that,
we get an extra
0.3 $1 million.
Yeah.
All right,
so we can do it at home.
We get an extra 0.3 $1 million,
so it turns out that our MBA student was right.
Good.
All right.
It turns out that you add this 0.31 to the 0.69 we had already,
we get one,
which of course is much bigger
than 0.7 and indeed you should rent the machine.
All right.
Now I want you to have to take away lessons from this game.
The first takeaway lesson is this.
When you're analyzing a game like this,
be it in the real world or in a job interview,
the first thing you want to do is what you want to look at the sub game.
You want to look what would happen if you did invest and so loud the knew Nash
equilibrium in that sub game.
Then you want to roll back the value of that sub,
game it back into the initial decision,
which is the strategic investment decision whether to buy this,
whether to rent this machine or not.
All right?
So schematically,
massively the game looks like this,
rent or not rent.
And in either case,
you play core,
no,
there's a sub game in each case.
In this case,
you play symmetric core.
No.
Okay.
When you both have the same costs,
and here you play asymmetric corn,
okay,
well you have different costs.
And the way we analyze this game is we've sold out the symmetric corner.
We actually did that up front.
We now sold out the new equilibrium and this asymmetric Cornell game,
this one here,
right?
This is the old one.
This is the new one.
Solve it out.
Work out how much profit you're going to get,
and roll that back.
Remembering that it costs 2.7 million to make this step.
So that's the first takeaway lesson.
But the second takeaway lesson is more general.
So let me just pause and get everyone to wake up again.
So I make it.
The second amendment takeaway lesson is this.
What tips the bands here from the economics answer and the accounting answer.
What are the strategic affects?
It was the strategic effects.
This was a strategic effects,
okay?
It was the effect of the other firm or other players changing their behavior and
the most common mistake to make when you're thinking about strategic decisions
is what?
It's to forget that they're strategic.
It's to forget that the other players are going to change their behavior.
In this example,
the other firm cuts back its production so much as to make that investment
profitable,
but let me give you two other examples.
Example.
Number one,
you're designing a tax policy for the u s the dumb way to analyze this is to
say,
look at what people are doing now.
Push through the new tax numbers and act like an accountant and crunch out how
much money the government's going to make,
right?
Why is that wrong?
Because you're forgetting that as you change the tax code,
people's behavior changes,
incentives change,
and people's behavior change.
It leads to a mistake in designing the tax code.
You need to take into account strategic effects,
how behavior changes.
Example number two,
closer to home,
you're designing a new curriculum for Yale.
So you change the rules of the curriculum and when analyzing it,
you say,
I wouldn't say this,
but some people on our committee might say this under these new rules,
if we look at what people used to do,
they will know,
do more of this and less of that,
and they'll learn this and learn that.
What are you missing?
You're missing that students are players and students change their behavior as
you change the curriculum rules.
All right,
so the,
the biggest lesson of today's pastor is don't be like an accountant,
partly because it's boring and you won't get,
you won't go on your dates and partly because you'll miss out on these important
strategic effects.
We'll come back and look at it more on Wednesday.